hello my name is steve jackson i'm an
applications development scientist at
thermo fisher scientific
and during today's talk i'm going to
present to you some of the solutions
that we have for dealing with the global
pandemic
now as we all know about a year ago our
world was changed immensely by
the sars kovi ii virus um at thermo
fisher's scientific
like everybody else in the world we were
hit with a need to
adapt to this this pandemic and
fortunately for thermo fisher scientific
we were in a position to be able to
offer the tools
and solutions for for people to
understand the the virus
understand how the pandemic was
progressing and understand how it might
be
dealt with so um the goal here at thermo
is to
provide high test high quality testing
solutions
and the pace at which is uh required to
address the the mutating virus
and the urgent society needs so what we
have done is we have
modified and mobilized our our supply
chains throughout the world
we have hired and trained a large number
of r d
resources that help develop innovative
solutions and we have deployed our field
support teams to help
our customers find the solutions and use
the solutions that are necessary for
dealing with the pandemic
as a result of this thermal fissure has
become the global leader in chronovirus
testing
currently more than half of the tests
that are being run are on thermo fissure
instruments
and using thermofisher reagents we have
gone from
no uh virus tests to over 20 million uh
virus tests per week manufacturing
capabilities
and again that that's a a very
large percentage of the number of tests
that are being run throughout the world
we have uh hardened our supply chains
and made it much more reliable so that
our customers
can rely on our tools being available to
them to
uh to do the testing and the the
surveillance
that is needed for for understanding the
pandemic and we also
again have our service and support team
which is there to help our customers
do the best science they possibly can
and meet the needs for for understanding
um this uh this uh challenge
as a result we would like to to
encourage people to think of thermo
fisher scientific as
as not just the supplier of tools but
the partner of solute partner of
solution providers we are are here to
help you
find ways to deal with pandemic and as a
result we have
our uh entire portfolio from of
end-to-end solutions available for for
uh coming up with solutions to help
solve the problems
and we have our supply chains and
innovations again that that
can be brought to bear on the problems
as they arise so
uh we're an ideal partner for helping
the the customers in
throughout the world make the world a
healthier place and help deal with this
pandemic
so a little bit about the viruses itself
of course we know that viruses mutate
rna virus like sars kobe 2 mutates at
very high rates
mutates at high rates and is response to
selective pressures like any
any organism does so continued
uncontrolled transmission of the virus
many parts of the world is causing many
many opportunities for the virus to
evolve
and although if the virus itself is on
the low end of the mutating
frequencies of other rna viruses it
still accumulates mutations at about one
to two mutations per month
but because there are so many people
throughout the world that have been
uh exposed to the virus and been
infected with the virus
there have been ample opportunities for
the virus to come up with new mutations
and some of these new mutations and
these new variant strains have acquired
the the ability to proliferate more
rapidly
become more infectious and present
certain challenges for controlling the
pandemic in the long run
some of the ways that these mutations
can affect the virus
and impact our our control of it are it
can alter the speed of transmission and
we have seen this with the the uk
variants uh the b117
variant some of the south african
variants brazilian variants other
variants that have
uh appeared as a result of the selective
pressure to to infect more people more
quickly
so the speed that they're you know more
transmissible
other types of variants can change the
severity of the phenotype
and again this was recently shown with
b117 variant
where uh it was published that that
variant appears to affect the the
mortality of of patients um that have
that that
um that particular variation so it can
change the severity of the
of the virus uh phenotype um it can
change the
susceptibility to inhibitory agents like
monoclonal antibodies
and specifically things like the
convalescent serum they might not
recognize some of the different uh
variants that are circulating it might
affect how how
it might affect their ability to to slow
the progression of the of the disease
these variants kind of evade the
vaccine-mediated immunity
um for example they could have a change
in the surface protein
the spike protein that that a that a
vaccine is made against and if that
happens and
the vaccine might not do any good and
finally that the variants can
impact the detection by pcr-based tests
and i'll have a little bit more to say
about that in the in the talk
so all together it's really important
for us to be able to track
changes in the virus in uh in the whole
population
and so um um it's it's again that the
the the public health groups are
are uh interested in monitoring the
viral genome detect these new mutations
as they arise
and determine the impact uh that this
might have on detection spread and
therapy
efficacies and in general um at thermal
fissure we have three prongs that are
they're used for
uh for for monitoring the progression of
changes in the virus on one hand we have
a
a a prong or a a a branch that is in
surveillance
this is for monitoring on the
changes of the virus in a population in
a more general way
and next generation sequencing capillary
solutions are ideal for for surveilling
how the
how the virus is changing within the
population in the yellow we have the
strain mutation verification branch and
this is
like this is for being able to
understand
which strain is infecting a particular
person and for verifying and and
and confirming that there are new
mutations present and in circulation
and for this again capital capital
electrophoresis is ideal for doing this
and we also have qpcr tools
uh which are useful for for uh tracking
and confirming that the mutations are
present
and then the very bottom we have a
detection uh using
a real-time piece uh reverse
transcription pcr
in these cases then it allows us to
detect the virus in a very specific way
but also using genotyping assays we can
we can queries
for specific mutations and and make
absolute determinations whether or not a
a single mutation is present in a
particular strain this helps us identify
this strain which might be in particular
individuals
and so altogether these three prongs
these three different solutions
help help us understand how the virus is
progressing and helps control
uh when and where it is is it is uh
transmitting in the populations
again this is a different way of looking
at our portfolio for for surveillance
and detection
we have a very deep portfolio as you as
you probably know ranging
from very high throughput to low
throughput uh uh
solutions for strain surveillance again
that the next generation sequencing is
ideal for discovery based uh
open-ended unbiased queries where you're
just looking to see
if anything new is present throughout
the entire genome
sanger sequencing is usually used for
for confirming that that
a a mutation is present for focusing on
in on a very defined region of the
genome and and
it's the gold standard for for for
sequence detection and so it's useful
for confirming that new mutations are
present
and finally a reverse transcription real
time pcr is useful for
detecting specific changes that are
there
our genotyping assays and our our gene
expression assays
allow for very precise and very
sensitive detection of of
single transcripts and single uh uh uh
nucleotide changes and so again uh these
these
three different strategies discovery
focus and detection
are all very useful for understanding uh
and tracking the
uh the progress of the virus in in the
world
so just to illustrate this i'm going to
give you an example um
recently we we partnered with the team
in ohio that sequenced genomes of of
um of people that were infected in march
uh
2020 since march 2020. and in january
2021 this team reported that there were
two novel variants that were identified
in the columbus ohio area
these were designated uh coh 20g 677h
and 20g 501y these are these were two
new variants unique to
to the ohio area that were identified as
a result of the surveillance
of the populations that are in ohio as a
result
there isn't much excitement about the
fact these new mutations
uh these new strains were found here it
was important for us to understand how
these might be transmissible and we now
have new tools to track how these
these these new variants were were
progressing in
in the area in the uh in the upper
midwest
and the way they did this was using a
thermo-fisher uh portfolio-based
solution so
they used the the king fresher
kingfisher flex
rna purification strategy for isolating
the the rna from samples
they used the taxpath combo complicate
for doing initial detection of sars kobe
2.
first for the the samples they wanted to
to verify that the the um
the the strain identity they they turned
to the ion torrent on the on chef
instruments
ion torrent next-gen sequencing and then
the the resulting software analysis of
the packages
of the of the data from the ion torrent
to confirm that these these changes were
present
and so in partnering with us they were
able to quickly go
from sample preparation all the way
through to an answer
and as a result they were able to
identify these new mutations and now
they have
a couple new sort of footholds in
in tracking new variants in the area
so um i'll basically mention that
uh a little bit more about the two
strategies for surveillance and then for
detection
for surveillance it's important for us
to be able to to see the um where
known uh sequences are are are
um are are uh uh
are moving where they are for their
present in populations where they are
you know that the the uh the identity of
particular strains particular
populations
and also we're surveilling to identify
new mutations as they arise in the
population
and so as i've mentioned before that
these the sanger sequencing targeted
genome focus
and a focus approach and the the whole
uh genome sequencing
discovery based approaches are ideal for
surveilling and tracking
uh entire uh viral genome strains
next generation sequencing um tends to
have a very high throughput because you
can multiplex many different samples on
a single
chip it does query the whole genome so
it's ideal for discovering new mutations
as they arise
it tends to have a longer turnaround
time and can be relatively expensive
on the other hand ce kepler
electrophoresis and sanger sequencing uh
has a little bit lower throughput than
the next generation sequencing
it allows us to focus in on very defined
regions um
and provides again this gold standard
sequencing
capabilities of of very focused uh
regions of the genome
the turnaround time can be relatively
fast and it has an intermediate cost
relatively speaking and and what i want
to emphasize from this is that next-gen
sequencing
and ce are complementary technologies
one is not going to be able to replace
the other one because they both have
strengths
next generation sequencing is ideal for
for whole genome queries
ce is ideal for querying focused regions
of the genome and so they both have a
place in
in tracking uh the variance for either
identifying very new mutations
or confirming those mutations or
focusing on regions where those
mutations might be present
and so we have a couple of not only
instrument
um options but we also have chemistry
options for surveillance um using uh
um next generation sequencing and
stanger sequencing
on the ion torrent platform we have the
ampliseq sars kobe 2 research assay
which is a single
prep which allows us to analyze 99
percent of the sars kobe 2 genome
it covers all potential genotypes that
are circulating right now of course
because it is a whole genome sequencing
solution
it can be used with with research
samples as low as 20 copies
um in in the sample um and and
once that you know a particular variant
is identified
oftentimes that's moved on to sanger 16
to confirm that a new
new variant is present very similar to
what's done in
oncology research for example
and then we have instrumentation we have
that the ion torrent
i'm sorry the ion chef and ion s5 series
instruments for library preparation and
sequencing and then we also have the
genexis uh
instrument which is integrated sample
preparation and sequencer which
uh simplifies the uh the whole
sequencing
workflow on the sanger sequencing side
we have um
again the the the industry standard for
sequencing that's been around for for
a very long time is very easy to run
sanger sequencing uh reactions um
it's very cost effective and provides
rapid confirmation that mutations are
present
and so we have several different
protocols that we have written that
allow us to
sequence the entire s gene for
identifying primer i'm sorry for
identifying mutations that are
characteristic of specific sequences
um and we also will be uh announcing in
the next week or so
um a protocol for uh choosing entire
saying or sequencing are
choosing saying or ceasing prime
minister anywhere in in the genome
this allows you then to confirm that new
mutations are present any place in the
in the
in the genome as necessary and as far as
the instrumentation again we run the
gamut from low throughputs seek studio
through the intermediate and up to high
throughput 3730 instruments that are
geared towards running
sanger sequencing solutions our our
sanger sequencing
chemistries will work on any of our
instruments
so the next the next thing i'll briefly
touch on is strategies for
mutation detection and verification in
these cases a lot of time you want to to
verify that as strain is present it's
less kind of surveillance and just
seeing what's out there it's more like
focusing on seeing
that a particular individual has a
particular strain or their their
taker sample has ticker strain so in
this case you yeah not many people
will run the the test to detect whether
or not the virus
is present and then they will either do
a real-time pcr
on a certain fraction of the samples to
uh to genotype them
and test whether or not a particular
strain contain a strain contains a
mutation
or they would sequence a focused region
of the
of the sample to see whether or not a
characteristic mutation of a strain is
present there
as i mentioned before that the sanger
sequencing run on ce is is
is a great uh tool for focusing the the
uh the real-time reverse transcription
pcr
is ideal for detecting very specific
mutations
and along these lines then we have
recently released
a panel or made available a panel of
taqman assays
which allow detection of some of the
most common um
nucleotide changes observance of these
different strains
the the turnaround time is very quick
and relative cost is relatively low
so again uh rt pcr
and ce are not necessarily there to
replace each other
um they both have strengths and
weaknesses for confirming the presence
of
very defined uh mutations and genotypes
and so one of the ways that this was uh
um uh
done was uh or what was uh used was um a
a case a research case that came out of
japan recently
um
of the professional prefectural
wealth health and welfare department in
japan
has a laboratory that runs about 50 qpcr
tests a day
and as a rule they sequence all the
tests that come out positive
and uh one of the tests that he ran on
his genexa sequencer
um turned out to be the the brazilian
variant that was circulating in brazil
this time but was not yet identified in
japan
as a result of this uh this test as a
result of this reflex test on genexis
who's able to confirm that the
um the uh the brazilian variant was
present
in this individual and this rapid
turnaround time less than 24 hours
allows the department to isolate the
individual that had this
the strain and kept the spread of this
brazilian variant in check
and so uh so far it has not spread that
much in japan
so good good demonstration of going from
a discovery to
characterization of the strain of
circulating and taking action against
that particular strain
and so uh again we we have a gamut of
tools that are available for for
for this uh this uh verification of
mutants
um that the the reverse transcription
rtq pcr
assays are are available they were just
recently released
these include assays that will detect
the 6970 deletion that's common in
in the uk and some other variants but
also other mutations in b117
and the south african b351 strains this
allows us to reflex the positive
covet 19 tests um onto
a a different set of assays
and confirm the presence or absence of
particular strains and
that the pacman assay palette is
customizable so you can choose which
assays are most appropriate for the
tests that you need around your
laboratory
and again these these assays are
designed to run on a large number of our
different qpcr
instruments from the the quantity five
real time up to the quant studio seven
and quantity
12 flex real-time instrument
and then again for confirming uh this
the uh the um
the presence of particular strain sanger
sequencing is a great tool for this
we have a a protocol that confirms
whether the 6970 deletion is present
and this works because of the primer sit
outside the region where this is and so
any mutations that might cause
for example the loss of a pcr test can
be confirmed
using sanger sequencing and again we
have designed protocols and primer
sequences that allow you to query
specific strains and ultimately anywhere
in the genome
okay so having having talked about in
the are the general strategies that we
have for
for um for surveillance i'm going to now
move on and focus a bit more on
on ce uh protocols that we have recently
developed that allow us to
to detect the strains
and so uh um people are quite familiar
with next-generation sequencing and
and tacman assays but the question often
arises
is why is ce relevant for this what can
sanger sequencing do
in in stars kobe 2 research and uh
one of the things that that that that
sanger is very useful for is confirming
the the unexpected results that come
from from
qpcr tests for example one of the ways
that the b117 strain was first
identified in
england was that there was an s gene
dropout
in tacpath assays that were being run
there
the the two other parts of the tacpath
assay were working just fine
but it was noted that the the s gene uh
probe was often coming up empty when
those tests were run
and so uh that unexpected result um was
uh was confirmed uh that the reason
behind that was was identified by sanger
sequencing the region
um of the 6970 deletion and confirming
that that particular mutation was over
the site where the
the probe was binding leading to the
loss of the of the of the
uh s gene results so that's just an
example i'll have a little bit more to
say about that in subsequent slides here
sanger sequencing is useful for for uh
verifying that a new mutation that
has been identified by next-generation
sequencing so if you have a
next-gen discovery based experiment and
you find that there is a
a new variant that you want to confirm
sanger sequencing is is very useful for
orthogonally determining that mutation
is present in the sample or other
other samples that have been collected
and sanger sequencing um is
is a is very useful for identifying new
variants
uh strains and lineages that can be
found by focusing in
with a very high precision and
confidence on particular regions of the
sars coe2 genome
it's not a whole genome sequencing
solution but it allows a very
precise analysis of particular regions
um using
a a gold standard chemistry
and then finally sanger sequencing can
be used um
in cases where uh we see instruments
might be sitting idle you know it
provides
an opportunity for for not only uh
confidence um in in some of these these
screening results
but can be used for testing on its own
and can open up some new new ways to to
test
um in in collective samples
so uh because of this uh thermo-fisher
scientific
has has come up some guidance about ways
that you might be able to use sanger
sequencing um again
it's the gold standard sequencing um um
mechanism uh the sanger sequencing
results are accepted by
by you know a vast majority of
scientists um
we have uh have developed very
robust protocols that allow you to
sequence regions of the genome
um it's when we have our solutions are
mostly cost effective
um and allow targeted sequencing as i've
sent throughout this this talk here
and and again for for confirming uh um
the the presence of of mutations uh we
have
um uh capacities for reflex testing the
s gene dropout like i just mentioned
it provides a rapid way to get an answer
because the sanger sequencing protocols
can be run in as little as a day
and uh we'll spend a little more time
through us to talk talking about the
protocols
that we have developed that allow you to
do various various things
as needed by your laboratory
this is a diagram of how sanger
sequencing might fit into a workflow
for example uh at the top you if you do
a detection workflow this is a pcr-based
workflow
uh you might receive a sample in your
laboratory extract rna from it
run the the real time pcr and analyze
the result
and as a result of that you would you
would have either the presence or
absence of
a virus in the sample there
and that might be good enough in some
instances but we have seen that there
are various other ways
that that more information is often
desired if you want to see if that
strain
is a particular variant that is
dangerous
if you want to see if that strain has a
mutation in a region that caused that
the pcr result to look a little
anomalous
or if you just want to surveil uh and
see what strains are circulating in the
population there
and so the bottom illustrates how the uh
the the uh sanger sequencing protocol
would work from that again you'll
receive a sample
extract rna do the the the pcr to
generate amplicons
subject that to the big direct big die
exterminator workflow to
cycle sequence run it on sanger and then
do the variant analysis and then with
that then we'll
tell you within the amplicons you've
sequenced if there are mutations present
now a lot of cases if you want a reflex
test you've come up with the reason to
to
to retest a sample that you you've
tested by
by pcr you can take that same rna that
you extracted from the
from the detection workflow and and jump
into the p
to the thing or sequencing protocol the
pcr step there
you don't have to extract new sample and
you can you can then use the exact same
sample for a confirmatory uh
or diagnostic uh uh test a a
a protocol diagnostic
analysis and so really this illustrates
that that sanger sequencing is a partner
for
for pcr-based surveillance techniques
okay and as i mentioned we have a couple
of of
protocols that we've recently recently
developed and made available to our
customers for
for doing the surveillance and and and
confirming uh
mutations um that are present the first
of these
is a protocol that focuses in on just
the 6970
deletion this particular
deletion as i mentioned is often seen in
b117s uh strains
uh and might also be present other
strains that are based
that are derived from the b117 mutation
um the way that this works is that in
order to to get the same sensitivity as
our attack path assay
we designed a pre-amplification uh step
and so we have pcr primers that flank
that the region to be queried uh in a
pre-amplification step we do a number of
cycles to generate a pre-product that
product is then subject to sequencing
using
primers that have m13 tails this allows
us to bypass
pcr purifications and jump right into
cycle sequencing using m13 primers
again this is this is the the chemistry
that our big direct
uh chemistry is based off of after the
the
the m13 cycle sequencing is performed at
the
the then the reactions are put directly
into the big dikes terminator cleanup
and then run on on the instrumentation
this big die direct big die exterminator
workflow is ideal because everything is
run in a single tube
there's no transfer of materials from
one tube to the other and and it really
saves on
on on pipetting steps the possibility of
getting cross contamination
or mixing up of samples there so this
protocol
was designed for reflex testing the pcr
tests that might
are suspected to have the 6970 deletions
and so on our website we have a uh the
protocol
posted we have a detailed protocol that
can that contains the sequences
uh the preamp and the m13 tailed primers
um we have the the the entire protocol
is available
in addition we have made an excel sheet
available which you can download
um this excel sheet has the primer
sequences
pre-entered and so you can take this
excel sheet and upload it to our primary
binding site and get the the primer
sequences ordered very quickly
and again this this protocol is ideal
for reflex testing
samples that might have are suspected to
have the 6970 deletion in it
the next protocol that we developed is
for confirming the presence of the b117
and the b1 351 string lineages and by
extension it's not on the slide here
but we have a similar sort of of
packages available for the the brazilian
p1 or b1 128 strains
the top of the slide just shows the
organization the source genome and it
emphasizes that throughout the genome
there are there are many mutations that
are characteristic of either the b117
or the south african strains again
scattered throughout the entire genome
so a single uh sanger sequence is not
going to be possible to detect it
so what we did for this uh for this
protocol was that we
designed a set of primers that will
query each position in the
in either the b117 or the south african
strains
or um it again we have the the pro the
primers designed for the brazilian
strain as well
um that the protocol available on
our websites is is available for
downloading and it contains a list of
all the primers that are that are
necessary for identifying each of the
mutations in these strains
now there's two things i want to say uh
um about this
first of all um it depends on what the
question is going to be whether or not
you need to have all of these primers
uh in your sequencing reactions in other
words you might decide that it's just
sufficiently uh
adequate to just do two or three to
confirm that b117
is is present or not or as particular
uh mutations are indicative of the south
african strains
so although we make the entire list of
primers present there are 19 primer
pairs that they will detect all the
different
mutations but they don't necessarily
have to be run
all at once so you are you can pick and
choose
which primer pairs are going to give you
the information that you want
the other thing is is like i mentioned
before we have an excel sheet that has
all the primer pairs
pre-loaded m13 tagged and available to
upload directly into our
our ordering page so you don't have to
manually enter
these sequences
um one of the ways that that i'd like to
illustrate the utility of this is again
based on one of our customer stories um
this is a customer that was in south
africa and this is when the south
african strains were just becoming
uh um identifiable uh in south africa
so he wanted to confirm the presence of
the mutations in these strains by sanger
sequencing
so together with him we designed the
primers that would allow us to
query uh indicative mutations uh in this
in the
south african strains in some cases the
mutations were closed clustered close
enough together that they could they
could be hit with a single
uh prime repair in other cases we had to
have to
make use of other primers to detect the
mutations there
so we came up with the uh uh four
characteristic mutations
um with with two primers we used the
protocol that i just uh
um described for you um and and we used
the thermal fischer portfolio again
going from the the
the pcr reactions the the sequencing
the cleanup and then the capital
electrophoresis
and what we were able to show is that
each one of the four samples that we
tested here had
had the different mutations present this
is an output from
our variant reporter software which
allows us to compare uh the
sequencing traces in samples with the
reference sequence here
i won't spend very much time on the
software itself it's available and and
easy
to use and download we will have some
guidance
documents on on data analysis of saying
or seasoning traces the next couple of
weeks
but here you can see that the the
regions highlighted in green indicate
that uh that
this is a a g to t change in each uh
each one of the samples and um i think
this is an a
yeah an a to t change each with the
different samples
again confirming that that sanger is
able to pick up these these different uh
changes and confirm they're there
so um the variant reporter software also
allows us to
uh to examine um the the
uh the electrophirograms um this is an
example from a window here from one of
the one of the variants
again focusing on the g to t change
um here you can see that the trace is
honed in
on this particular uh change here
what we see is the forward and reverse
uh uh traces
that were lined up so you can see the
quality of the of the sequencing traces
and and uh examine and make sure that
that particular uh variant is real if he
needs to
so again we've made the data analysis
very easy using variant reporter
and also by uh not shown in this talk
but we also have
guidance coming for seekscape so
our tools are available for you using or
sequencing to to confirm
uh the presence of variants
so the third protocol that we developed
is for focusing in on the s gene
now the spike gene of the sars
coronavirus is is very important because
as you know it
is the the major protein for binding h2
receptors and for entry into cells
um so changes in the s chain sequence
can affect
its binding to the the h2 receptor and
and
and and affect its entry into into cells
and
affect its infectivity um it's also the
major uh um
target for vaccine uh development and so
um again if there are any changes in the
in the s protein sequence um this could
affect the
the efficacy of of vaccines and so
we wanted to come up with a protocol
that allows researchers to identify
changes that might be present anywhere
in the s gene itself
and so we have again a detailed protocol
that we developed
and a set of primers that that will uh
tile across the entire s gene
and allow you to sequence all about 4
000 nucleotides of the s
gene um
by sanger sequencing there are 12 primer
pairs that that we
use for for doing this and you can
either use all 12 primer pairs to
sequence or you can pick and choose
which region of the s
protein is of most interest to you and
focus in using uh
primer pairs that that are picked
specifically for that purpose
um we like the other protocols we have a
um a
excel sheet that is pre-loaded with the
the sequences necessary for sequencing
the ss protein
so uh this is another very valuable tool
that allow us to uh
to focus in on the s gene and and see
how that might be changing
um in for example samples that
may have not responded to a vaccine for
example you might want to sequence the s
protein from those particular isolates
and see if there are changes that can be
correlated with loss of vaccine efficacy
very important for research purposes
the last thing i'll tell you about is a
guidance that we're going to to feature
for sequencing any region of the
of the sars kobe 2 genome the cyrus kobe
2 geno itself is about 30 000
nucleotides long and it's not very
practical to sequence that entire thing
with sanger sequencing
but what we're going to be offering uh
our customers are
a browser that allows you to visualize
the
the the layout of the sars code ii
genome and particular mutations in that
genome
and where the sanger sequencing primers
are relative to those features of the
genome itself
and so you can then visually see where
in the genome mutations map find the
primers necessary to cover that mutation
and
order them in addition we're going to
have
a lookup table that allow you to put in
any
coordinates any strains any mutations
and we will be able to
to pull out the sanger sequencing
primers allow you to to sequence that
particular region
this is under development we expect to
have this right in a couple of weeks
we also plan to have some data analysis
guideline features which will allow you
to uh to take the the sanger seeks in
traces
um and perform some quality control
checks
and cross checking against defined
strains to see whether or not they are
present in a particular sample
again we hope to have these ready in a
couple of weeks
okay so i just want to conclude by
reminding you that thermo fisher
scientific is your trusted partner for
surveillance solutions
that that will help you identify detect
and confirm
that new mutations are present and help
confirm and detect
emerging new strains and variants and
again our multi
multi-pronged approach of strain
surveillance
strain detection and um
and strain uh mutation verification
these three different prongs uh play
uh important roles in surveillance and
understanding
um how the virus is is mutating
how it is being transmitted and how it
can be controlled in the population
um i also want to reiterate that uh that
we have
hardened our supply chains uh we have
the ability to respond very quickly and
very massively to the needs of of the
researchers as as the pandemic
progresses and hopefully uses
and we also have the one trusted source
for integrated solutions and for
services support of those solutions
as needed we want to make sure that
you're successful with your science
that you're successful with your uh with
your testing um and
successful in your mechanism and your
means for controlling the pandemic
because we know that that that this is a
a an important
time for controlling the sars kobe 2
pandemic
but i think we all know that there is uh
more
on the horizon um that the unknown
pandemic
are out there and we want to be able to
respond
just as quickly when the next one comes
around and help mitigate
the issues that might arise in the
future
so finally i want to thank you very much
for your time and i'll be happy to take
questions now
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled solutions for sars co v2 strain
lineage surveillance
this webinar is part of the coronavirus
virtual event series
i am sabrina lemos of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and sponsored by thermo fisher
scientific for more information about
thermal fissure scientific
go to thermofisher.com now let's get
started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the ask a question box located to the
far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker stephen
jackson
associate director product applications
genetic sciences division at thermo
fisher scientific
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
to the top right of your screen stephen
you may now begin your presentation
hello my name is steve jackson i'm an
applications development scientist at
thermo fisher scientific
and during today's talk i'm going to
present to you some of the solutions
that we have for dealing with the global
pandemic
now as we all know about a year ago our
world was changed
immensely by the sars kovi 2 virus
at thermo fisher's scientific like
everybody else in the world we were hit
with a need to
adapt to this this pandemic and
fortunately for thermal fissure
scientific we were in a position to be
able to offer the tools
and solutions for for people to
understand the the virus
understand how the pandemic was
progressing and understand how it might
be
dealt with so um the goal here at thermo
is to
provide um high test high quality
testing solutions
and the pace at which is uh required to
address the the mutating virus
and the urgent society needs so what we
have done is we have uh
modified and mobilized our supply chains
throughout the world
we have hired and and trained a large
number of r d resources that help
develop innovative solutions
and we have deployed our field support
teams to help our customers find the
solutions and use the solutions
that are necessary for dealing with the
pandemic
as a result of this thermal fissure has
become the global leader in chronovirus
testing
currently more than half of the tests
that are being run are on thermo fissure
instruments
and using thermo fissure reagents we
have gone from
no virus tests to over 20 million
virus tests per week manufacturing
capabilities and
again that that's a a very large
uh percentage of the number of tests
that are being run throughout the world
we have uh hardened our supply chains
and made it much more reliable so that
our customers
can rely on our tools being available to
them to
uh to do the testing and the the
surveillance
that is needed for for understanding the
pandemic and we also again have our
service and support team which is there
to help our customers
do the best science they possibly can
and meet the needs for for understanding
this this challenge
as a result we would like to to
encourage people to think of thermo
fisher scientific as as not just the
supplier of tools
but the partner of solute partner of
solution providers we are are here to
help you
find ways to deal with pandemic and as a
result we have
our entire portfolio from of end-to-end
solutions available for for
uh coming up with with solutions to help
solve the problems
and we have our supply chains and
innovations again that that
can be brought to bear on the problems
as they arise so uh
we're an ideal partner for helping that
the the customers in the throughout the
world
make the world a healthier place and
help deal with this pandemic
so a little bit about the viruses itself
of course we know that viruses mutate
rna virus like sars kobe 2 mutates at
very high rates
mutates at high rates and is response to
selective pressures like any any
organism does
so continued uncontrolled transmission
of the virus many parts of the world is
causing many many
opportunities for the virus to evolve
and although
if the virus itself is on the low end of
the mutating
frequencies of other rna viruses it
still accumulates mutations at about one
to two mutations per month
but because there are so many people
throughout the world that have been
uh exposed to the virus and been
infected with the virus
there have been ample opportunities for
the virus to come up with new mutations
and some of these new mutations and
these new variant strains have acquired
the the ability to proliferate more
rapidly
become more infectious and present
certain challenges for controlling that
the pandemic in the long run
some of the ways that these mutations
can affect the virus
and impact our our control of it are it
can alter the speed of transmission and
we have seen this with the the uk
variants uh the b117
variant some of the south african
variants brazilian variants other
variants that have
appeared as a result of the selective
pressure to to infect more people more
quickly
so the speed that they're you know more
transmissible
other types of variants can change the
severity of the phenotype
and again this was recently shown b117
variant
where uh uh it was published that that
variant appears to affect the
the mortality of of patients that have
that that
that particular variation so it can
change the severity of the of the virus
phenotype um it can change the
susceptibility to inhibitory agents like
monoclonal antibodies
and specifically things like the
convalescent serum uh they might not
recognize some of the different uh
uh variants that are circulating it
might affect how
how it might affect their ability to to
slow the progression of the of the
disease
these variants kind of evade the
vaccine-mediated immunity
for example they could have a change in
the surface protein
the spike protein that that a that a
vaccine is made against and if that
happens and that the vaccine might not
do any good
and finally that the variance can impact
the detection by pcr-based tests and
we'll have a little bit more to say
about that in the in the talk
so altogether it's really important for
us to be able to to track
um changes in the virus um in uh
in the whole population and so um
um it's it's again that the the public
health groups are
are interested in monitoring the viral
genome detect these new mutations as
they arise
and determine the impact that this might
have on detection spread
and and therapy efficacies and in
general um at thermal fissure we have
three prongs that are they're used for
uh for um for monitoring the progression
of
of changes in the virus um on one hand
we have a
a a prong or a a a branch that is in
surveillance
this is for monitoring on the
changes of the virus in a population in
a more general way
and next generation sequencing capillary
solutions are are ideal for for
surveilling how the
how the virus is changing within the
population in the yellow we have that
the string mutation verification branch
and this is for like
this is for being able to understand um
which strain is infecting a particular
person and for verifying and
and confirming that there are new
mutations present and in circulation
and for this again capital capital
electrophoresis is ideal for doing this
and we also have qpcr tools
uh which are useful for for uh tracking
and confirming that the mutations are
present
and then the very bottom we have a
detection uh
a real-time piece verse transcription
pcr
in these cases then it allows us to
detect the virus in a very specific way
but also using genotyping assays we can
we can queries
for specific mutations and and make
absolute determinations whether or not a
a single mutation is present in a
particular strain and this helps us
identify this strain which might be in
in particular individuals
and so uh altogether these three prongs
these three different solutions
help help us understand how the virus is
progressing and helps control
when and where it is is it is
transmitting in the populations
again this is a different way of looking
at our portfolio for for surveillance
and detection
um we have a very deep portfolio as you
as you probably know
ranging from very high throughput to low
throughput uh
uh solutions for strain surveillance
again
the next generation sequencing is ideal
for discovery based
open-ended unbiased queries where you're
just looking to see
uh if anything new is present throughout
the entire genome
um sanger sequencing is usually used for
for confirming that that
a a mutation is present for focusing on
in on a very defined region of the
genome um and and it's the gold standard
for
for for sequence detection and so it's
useful for confirming that new mutations
are present
and finally reverse transcription
real-time pcr is useful for
detecting specific changes that are
there
our genotyping assays and our gene
expression assays
allow for very precise and very
sensitive detection of
single transcripts and single uh uh
nucleotide changes and so again uh these
these three different strategies
discovery focus and detection
are all very useful for understanding uh
and tracking the
the progress of the virus in in the
world
so just to illustrate this i'm going to
give you an example um
recently we partnered with the team in
ohio that sequenced genomes of people
that were infected in march
uh 2020 since march 2020. and in january
2021 this team reported that there were
two novel variants that were identified
in the columbus ohio area
these were designated uh coh 20g 67h
and 20g501y these are these were two new
variants unique to
to the ohio area that were identified as
a result of the surveillance
of the populations that are in ohio as a
result
there isn't much excitement about the
fact these new mutations
uh these new strains were found here it
was important for us to understand how
these might be transmissible and we now
have new tools to track how these
these these new variants were were
progressing in
in the area in the uh in the upper
midwest
and the way they did this was using a
thermo-fisher uh portfolio-based
solution so
they used the the king fresher
kingfisher flex
rna purification strategy for isolating
the the rna from samples
they use the taxpath combo kit for doing
the initial detection of of sars kobe 2.
first for the the samples they wanted to
to verify that
the um the the strain identity they they
turned to the ion torrent uh
on chef instruments and ion torrent
next-gen sequencing
and then that the the resulting software
analysis of the packages
of the of the data from the ion torrent
to confirm that these these chains were
present
and so in partnering with us they were
able to to quickly go
from sample preparation all the way
through to an answer um
and as a result they were able to
identify these new mutations and now
they have
a couple new sort of footholds uh in
in tracking new variants in the area
so um i'll basically mention that
a little bit more about the two
strategies for surveillance and then for
detection
for surveillance it's important for us
to be able to to see
the um where known uh sequences are are
our um are our uh
are moving where they are for their
present in populations where they are
you know that the the uh the identity of
particular strains particular
populations
and also we're surveilling to to
identify new mutations as they arise in
the population
and so as i've mentioned before that
these the uh sanger sequencing target
genome focus
and a focus approach and the the whole
uh genome sequencing
discovery based approaches are ideal for
surveilling and tracking
entire uh viral genome strains next
generation sequencing
tends to have a very high throughput
because you can multiplex many different
samples on a single
chip it does query the whole genome so
it's ideal for discovering new mutations
as they arise
it tends to have a longer turnaround
time and can be relatively expensive
on the other hand uh ce kepler
electrophoresis and sanger sequencing uh
has a little bit lower throughput than
the next generation sequencing
it allows us to focus in on very defined
regions um
and provides again this gold standard
sequencing uh um
capabilities of of very focused uh
regions of the genome
the turnaround time can be relatively
fast and it has an intermediate cost
relatively speaking um and what i want
to emphasize from this is that next-gen
sequencing and ce
are complementary technologies one is
not going to be able to replace the
other one because they both have
strengths
next generation sequencing is ideal for
for whole genome queries
ce is ideal for querying focused regions
of the genome and so they both have a
place in
in tracking uh the variants for either
identifying very new mutations
or confirming those mutations or
focusing on regions where those
mutations might be present
and so we have a couple of not only
instrument
options but we also have chemistry
options for surveillance
using next generation sequencing and
standard sequencing
on the ion torrent platform we have the
ampliseq sars kobe 2 research assay
which is a single
uh prep which allows us to analyze
ninety-nine percent of the sars-kobe-2
genome
it covers all potential genotypes that
are circulating right now of course
because it is a whole genome sequencing
solution
it can be used with with research
samples as low as 20 copies
in in the sample um and and
once that you know a particular variant
is identified
oftentimes that's moved on to sanger 16
to confirm that a new
new variant is present very similar to
what's done in
oncology research for example
and then we have the instrumentation we
have that that the ion torrent
sorry the ion chef and ion s5 series
instruments for library preparation and
sequencing and then we also have the
genexis
uh instrument which is integrated sample
preparation and sequencer which
uh simplifies the uh the whole
sequencing uh
workflow on the sanger sequencing side
we have um
again the the the industry standard for
sequencing that's been around for
for a very long time is very easy to
run sanger sequencing uh uh reactions um
it's very cost effective and provides
rapid confirmation that mutations are
present
and so we have several different
protocols that we have written that
allow us to
sequence the entire s gene um for
identifying primary i'm sorry for
identifying mutations that are
characteristic of specific sequences
and we also will be announcing in the
next week or so
a protocol for uh choosing entire sanger
sequencing
choosing sanger cc prime minister
anywhere in in the genome
this allows you then to confirm that new
mutations are present any place in the
in the
in the genome as necessary and as far as
the instrumentation again we run the
gamut from low throughputs uh seek
studio
through the intermediate and up to high
throughput 3730 instruments that are
geared towards running
sanger sequencing solutions our our
sanger sequencing uh
chemistries will work on any of our our
instruments
so the next the next thing i'll briefly
touch on
is strategies for mutation detection and
verification
in these cases a lot of time you want to
to verify that a strain is present it's
less kind of surveillance and just
seeing what's out there it's more like
focusing on seeing
that a particular individual has a
particular strain or their their
taker sample has ticker strain so in
this case you yeah
many people will run the the test to
detect whether or not the virus is
present
and then they will either do a real-time
pcr on a certain fraction of the samples
to uh to genotype them
and test whether or not a particular
strain contain
a strain contains a mutation or they
would sequence uh
a focused region of the of the sample to
see whether or not
a characteristic mutation of a strain is
present there
as i mentioned before that the sanger
sequencing run on ce
is is is a great uh tool for focusing
the
the uh the real-time reverse
transcription pcr is ideal for detecting
very specific
mutations and along these lines then we
have recently released
a panel or made available a panel of
taqman assays
which allow detection of some of the
most common um
nucleotide changes observed in some of
these different strains
the the turnaround time is very quick
and relative cost is relatively low
so again uh uh rt pcr
and ce are not necessarily there to
replace each other
um they both have strengths and
weaknesses for confirming the presence
of
very defined uh mutations and genotypes
and so one of the ways that this was uh
um
done was uh was uh used was
um a a case a research case that came
out of
japan recently um uh
dr ryo kyoujima um of the uh
professional uh
prefectural uh wealth health and welfare
department
in japan uh has a laboratory that runs
about 50 qpcr tests a day
and as a rule they sequence all the
tests that come out positive
and uh one of the tests that he ran on
his genexa sequencer
turned out to be the the brazilian
variant that was circulating in brazil
at this time but was not yet identified
in japan
as a result of this uh this test as a
result of this reflex test on genexis he
was able to confirm that the
um the the brazilian variant was present
in this individual and this rapid
turnaround time less than 24 hours
allows the department to isolate the
individual that had this
the strain and kept the spread of this
brazilian variant in check
and so so far it has not spread that
much in japan
it's a good good demonstration of going
from
a discovery to
characterization of the strain of
circulating and and taking action
against that particular strain
and so again we we have a gamut of tools
that are available for
for for this uh this uh verification of
mutants
um that the the reverse transcription
rtqpcr
assays are are available they were just
recently released
these include assays that will detect
the 6970 deletion that's common in in
the uk and some other variants but also
other mutations in b117
and the south african b351 strains um
this allows us to reflex the positive
covet 19 tests um onto
a a different set of assays
and confirm the presence or absence of
particular strains
and that the pacman assay palette is
customizable so you can choose which
assays are most appropriate for the
tests that you need are in your
laboratory
and again these these assays are
designed to run on a large number of our
different qpcr instruments from the the
quantity 5 real time up to the quant
studio 7 and quantity
12 flex real-time instrument
and then again for confirming uh this
the uh the um
the presence of particular strain sanger
sequencing is a great tool for this
we have a a protocol that confirms
whether the 6970 deletion is present
and this works because the primer sit
outside the region where this is and so
any mutations that might cause
for example the loss of a pcr test can
be confirmed
uh using sanger sequencing and again we
have
design protocols and primer sequences
that allow you to query uh specific
strains
and ultimately anywhere in the genome
okay so having having talked about in
the are the general strategies that we
have for
for for surveillance i'm going to now
move on and focus a bit more on on ce
uh protocols that we have recently
developed that allow us to
to detect the strains
and so uh um people are quite familiar
with next generation sequencing and
and attack then assays but the question
often arises
is why is ce relevant for this what can
sanger sequencing do
in in stars kobe 2 research and uh
one of the things that uh that that
sanger is very useful for is confirming
the the unexpected results that come
from from
qpcr tests for example one of the ways
that the b117 strain was first
identified in
england was that there was an s gene
dropout
uh in tact path assays um that were
being run there
the the two other parts of the tacpath
assay were working just fine
but it was noted that the the s gene uh
probe was often
coming up empty when those tests were
run
and so that unexpected result um was
was confirmed that the reason behind
that was was identified by saying or
sequencing the region
of the 6970 deletion and confirming that
that particular mutation was over the
site where the
the probe was binding leading to the
loss of the of the of the
uh s gene results so that's just an
example i'll have a little bit more to
say about that in subsequent slides here
um sanger sequencing is useful for for
uh verifying that a new mutation that
has been identified by next-generation
sequencing so if you have a
next-gen discovery based experiment and
you find that there is a
a new variant that you want to confirm
sanger sequencing is is very useful for
orthogonally determining that that
mutation is present in the sample or
other
other samples that have been collected
and sanger sequencing um
is is a is very useful for
identifying new variants uh strains and
lineages
that that can be found by focusing in um
with a very high
precision and confidence on particular
regions of the sars coe2 genome
it's not a whole genome sequencing
solution but it allows a very precise
uh analysis of particular regions
um using a a gold standard chemistry
and then finally sanger sequencing can
be used um
in cases where we see instruments might
be sitting idle you know it provides
an opportunity for for uh not only uh
confidence um in in some of these these
screening results
but can be used for testing on its own
and can open up some new new ways to to
test
in in collective samples
so uh because of this uh thermofisher
scientific
has has come up some guidance about ways
that you might be able to use sanger
sequencing
again it's the gold standard sequencing
um
mechanism on the sanger sequencing
results are accepted by
by you know a vast majority of
scientists um
we have uh have developed very
robust protocols that allow you to
sequence regions of the genome
um it's when we have our solutions are
mostly cost effective
um and allow targeted sequencing as i
have i've sent throughout this this talk
here
and and again for for confirming uh um
uh
the the presence of of mutations we have
capacities for reflex testing the s gene
dropout like i just mentioned
it provides a rapid way to get an answer
because the sanger sequencing protocols
can be run in as little as a day
and uh we'll spend a little more time
through us to talk talking about the
protocols
that we have developed that allow you to
do various uh various things um as
needed by your laboratory
this is a diagram of how sanger
sequencing might fit into a workflow
for example at the top you if you do a
detection workflow this is a
pcr based workflow you might receive a
sample in your laboratory extract rna
from it
run the the real-time pcr and analyze
the result
and as a result of that you would you
would have either the presence or
absence of
a virus in the sample there
and that might be good enough in some
instances but we have seen that there
are various other ways
that that more information is often
desired if you want to see if that
strain
is a particular variant that is
dangerous
if you want to see if that strain has a
mutation in a region that caused that
the pcr result to look a little
anomalous
or if you just want to surveil uh and
see what strains are circulating in the
population there
and so the bottom illustrates how the
the the
sanger sequencing protocol would work
from that again you receive a sample
extract rna do the the the pcr to
generate amplicons
subject that to the big direct big diax
terminator workflow to
cycle sequence run it on sanger and then
do the variant analysis and then with
that then
they'll tell you within the amplicons
you've sequenced if there are mutations
present
now a lot of cases if you want a reflex
test you've come up with the reason to
to
to retest a sample that you you've
tested by
by pcr you can take that same rna that
you extracted from the
from the detection workflow and and jump
into the p
to the thing or sixteen protocols the
pcr step there
you don't have to extract new sample and
you can you can then use the exact same
sample for a confirmatory
uh or diagnostic uh test a a protocol
diagnostic
analysis and so really this illustrates
that that sanger sequencing is a partner
for
for pcr-based surveillance techniques
okay and as i mentioned we have a couple
of
of protocols that we've recently
recently developed and made available to
our customers for
for doing the surveillance and and and
confirming uh
mutations um that are present
the first of these is a protocol that
focuses in on just the 6970 deletion
um this particular uh deletion as i
mentioned is often seen in b117s
strains uh and might also be present
other strains
that that are based that are derived
from the b117 mutation
um the way that this works is that in
order to to get the same sensitivity as
our attack path assay
we designed a pre-amplification uh step
and so we have pcr primers that flank
that the region to be queried uh in a
pre-amplification step we do a number of
cycles to generate a pre-product
that product is then subject to
sequencing using uh primers that have
m13 tails
this allows us to bypass
pcr purifications and jump right into
cycle sequencing using m13 primers
again this is this is the the chemistry
that our big die direct
chemistry is based off of after the the
the m13
cycle sequencing is performed at the the
then um the reactions are put directly
to the big die exterminator cleanup
um and then run on on the
instrumentation
this big direct big die exterminator
workflow is ideal because everything is
run in a single tube
there's no transfer of materials from
one tube to the other and and it really
saves on
on on pipetting steps the possibility of
getting cross-contamination
or mixing up of samples there so this
protocol
was designed for reflex testing the pcr
test that might are
suspected to have the 6970 deletions
and so on our website um we have a uh
the protocol posted we have the detailed
protocol that can
that contains the sequences uh the
preamp
and the m13 tail primers we have that
the the
the entire protocol is available and in
addition we have made an excel sheet
available which you can download
um this excel sheet has the primer
sequences
pre-entered and so you can take this
excel sheet and upload it to our primary
binding site and get the the the primer
sequences ordered very quickly
and again this this protocol is ideal
for reflex testing
samples that might have are suspected to
have the 6970 deletion in it
the next protocol that we developed is
for confirming the presence of the b117
and the b1351 strain lineages and by
extension it's not on this slide here
but we have a similar sort of of
packages available for the the brazilian
p1 or b1 128 strains
the top of the slide just shows the
organization the source genome and it
emphasizes that throughout the genome
there are there are many mutations that
are characteristic of either the b117
or the south african strains again
scattered throughout the entire genome
so a single uh sanger sequence is not
going to be possible to detect it
so what we did for this uh for this
protocol was that we
um designed a set of primers that will
query each position in the
in either the b117 or the south african
strains
or um it again we have the the
primers designed for the brazilian
strain as well
um the the protocol available on our
websites is is available for downloading
and it contains a list of all the
primers that are that are necessary for
identifying each of the mutations
in these strains now there are two
things i want to say
about this first of all it depends on
what the question is going to be whether
or not you need to have all of these
primers
in your sequencing reactions in other
words you might decide that it's just
sufficiently uh
adequate to just do two or three to
confirm the b117 is
is present or not or as particular uh
mutations are indicative of the south
african strains so although we make
the entire list of primers present there
are 19 primer pairs that they will
detect all the different uh
mutations but they don't necessarily
have to be run um
all at once so you are you can pick and
choose
which prime pairs are going to give you
the information that you want
the other thing is is like i mentioned
before we have an excel sheet that has
all of the primer pairs
pre-loaded m13 tagged and available to
upload directly into our
our ordering page so you don't have to
manually enter
these sequences
one of the ways that i'd like to
illustrate the utility of this is again
based on one of our customer stories
this is a customer that was in south
africa and this is when the south
african strains were just becoming
identifiable in south africa so he
wanted to confirm the presence of the
mutations in these strains by sanger
sequencing so together with him we
designed
primers that would allow us to query uh
indicative mutations uh in this in the
south african strains in some cases the
mutations were close clustered close
enough together that they could they
could be hit with a single
uh prime repair in other cases we had to
have to
make use of other primers to detect
mutations there
so we came up with the uh four
characteristic mutations
um with with two primers we used the
protocol that i just uh um
described for you and and we use the
thermo fisher portfolio again going from
the the the um the pcr reactions
the the sequencing the cleanup and then
the capital electrophoresis
and what we were able to show is that
each one of the four samples that we
tested here had
had the different mutations present this
is an output from our variant reporter
software which allows us to compare uh
this sequencing traces in samples with
the reference sequence here
i won't spend very much time on the
software itself it's available
and and easy to use and download
we will have some guidance documents on
on
data analysis of saying or 16 traces the
next couple of weeks
but here you can see that the the
regions highlighted in green
indicate that uh that this is a a g
to t change in each uh each one of the
samples
and i think this is an a yeah an a to t
change each of the different samples um
again confirming that that sanger was
able to pick up these these different
changes and confirm that they're there
so um the variant reporter software also
allows us to
uh to examine um the the
uh the electrophirograms um this is an
example from a window here from one of
the one of the variants again
focusing on the g to t change um here
you can see that the
the trace is honed in um on this
particular uh
uh change here what we see is the
forward and reverse
uh uh traces that were lined up so you
can see the quality of the of the
sequencing traces
and and examine and make sure that that
particular uh variant is real if he
needs to
so again we've made the data analysis um
very easy using variant reporter
and also by uh not shown in this talk
but we also have uh guidance coming
for seekscape so um our tools are
available for
uh you use singer sequencing to to
confirm uh
the presence of variants
so the third protocol that we developed
is for focusing in on the s gene
now the spike gene of the sars
chronoviruses is very important because
as you know it is the the major protein
for binding to h2 receptors and for
entry into cells
um so changes in the s chain sequence
can affect its binding to the
the h2 receptor and and and and affect
its entry into
into cells and affect its infectivity
um it's also the major uh um target for
vaccine uh development and so um
again if there are any changes in in the
s protein sequence
this could affect the the efficacy of
vaccines and so we wanted to come up
with a protocol that allows uh
researchers to
identify changes that might be present
anywhere in the s gene itself
and so we have again a detailed protocol
that we developed
and a set of primers that that will uh
tile across the entire s gene
and allow you to sequence all about four
thousand nucleotides of the s gene
um um by saying or sequencing
um there are twelve prime repairs that
that we use for for doing this
and you can either use all 12 prime
repairs to sequence or you can pick and
choose which region of the s protein
is of most interest to you and focus in
using uh
primer pairs that that are picked
specifically for that purpose
um we like the other protocols we have a
um
a excel sheet that is pre-loaded with
the the sequences necessary for
sequencing the ss protein
so uh this is another very valuable tool
that allow us to uh
to focus in on the s gene and and see
how that might be changing in for
example
samples that may have not responded to a
vaccine for example you might want to
sequence the s protein from those
particular isolates
and see if there are changes that can be
correlated with loss of vaccine efficacy
very important for research purposes
the last thing i'll tell you about uh is
a
guidance that we're going to to feature
for sequencing any region of the
of the sars kobe 2 genome the cyroscopy
2 genome itself is about 30
000 nucleotides long and it's not very
practical to sequence that entire thing
with sanger
sequencing but what we're going to be
offering uh
our customers are um a browser that
allows you
to visualize the the the layout of the
sars cov2 genome
and particular mutations in that genome
and where the sanger sequencing primers
are relative to those features of the
genome itself
and so you can then visually see where
uh
in the genome mutations map find the
primers necessary to cover that mutation
and order them
in addition we're going to have a lookup
table
that allow you to put in any uh
coordinates any strains
any mutations and we will be able to to
pull up the sanger sequencing primers
allow you to sequence that particular
region
this is under development we expect to
have this ready in a couple of weeks
we also plan to have some data analysis
guideline features which will allow you
to uh
to take the the sanger seeking traces
and perform some quality control checks
and cross checking against defined
strains to see whether or not they are
present in a particular sample
again we hope to have these ready in a
couple of weeks
okay so i just want to conclude by
reminding you that thermo fisher
scientific is your trusted partner for
surveillance solutions
that that will help you identify detect
and confirm that new mutations are
present
and help confirm and detect emerging
new strains and variants and again our
multi multi-pronged approach
of strain surveillance strain detection
uh and um and strain uh
mutation verification these three
different prongs uh play
uh important roles in surveillance and
understanding
how the virus is is mutating how it is
being transmitted
and how it can be controlled in the
population
um i also want to reiterate that that we
have
pardoned our supply chains we have the
ability to respond very quickly and very
massively to the needs of the
researchers as the pandemic progresses
and hopefully eases
and we also have the one trusted source
for integrated solutions and for service
and support of those solutions
um um as needed we want to make sure
that you're successful with your science
that you're successful with your uh with
your testing um and
successful in your mechanism and your
means for controlling the pandemic
because we know that that this is a a an
important
time for controlling the sars kobe 2
pandemic
but i think we all know that there is uh
more
on the horizon um that the unknown
pandemic
are out there and we want to be able to
respond
just as quickly when the next one comes
around and help mitigate
the issues that might arise in the
future
so finally i want to thank you very much
for your time and i'll be happy to take
questions now
stephen for your informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
you just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen let's get started
our first question why would we still
need to confirm a positive result
with ngs or sanger if they get a
positive
with the qpcr mutation assay
so the reason you do that is because
that the the qpcr will tell you whether
or not a particular
single mutation a single nucleotide
change is present but it doesn't tell
you anything else about the rest of the
virus that's there
and so you can you can easily tell that
there is sars cov2 present you might be
able to tell whether or not there's a
particular genotype present
in a different assay but it really
doesn't tell you anything about the
whole rest of the
of the sequence of the of the genome and
so using sanger to focus in on
particular regions or using next gender
to
to query the whole genome will give you
a lot more information about about
the uh the the the whole structure of
the genome
and may allow you to to um hypothesize
where it came from
um other effects it might have based on
on what's known about the biology of the
virus and other mutations that might be
present
and just gives you a lot more
information just a single uh detection
qpcr result will tell you again i want
to emphasize that these three
approaches the discovery next generation
sequencing the focusing
sanger sequencing and the detection pcr
are complementary approaches
they give you different answers to
different questions and
and based on what you need to know and
and how you want to know it
the the right tool is there for you
wonderful thank you um one question from
our audience member
um thermo fisher has three sanger
protocols to sanger sequencing sars kovi
two variants
one is s gene one is 6970
del the other covers uk and africa
strange
strains excuse me how would you
recommend
choosing and picking um one or all of
these protocols for covid patients
testing in a clinical lab
so uh you know i think that that the
the approach you choose is going to
depend on on what you would like to know
for example the 6970 deletion protocol
is meant to provide a reflex test a
double check
on those samples where the tac path
assay has failed in the s gene we have
esteem dropout with attack path assay
and so that 6970 deletion uh protocol
is designed specifically for checking
verifying that the s gene is present
but but the um the the tac
path assay is is not able to work
because particular regions of the s gene
have been deleted
regions where the primer or probes would
bind it's a way of confirming that that
you you do have virus there
even though you're getting uh one of the
three uh attack path uh
probes to drop out the b117 the the b
one 351 and the p1 strain protocols
are there for those laboratories that
want to confirm that there is one of
those strains circulating in their
population
those those protocols are there that
allow you to confirm that there are very
specific changes that are that have been
defined for those different strains
that they are present in in a particular
sample so the the those are there
for for querying specifically uh that
that you have one of these
variants of concern circulating in your
population
and finally the s gene uh the entire s
gene protocol are
mostly there for people that want to
identify new mutations that are anywhere
in the s gene itself and in particular
these are our
import for people that are trying to
understand how
changes in the s gene might affect the
uh ace2 binding if you for example
suspect a
a new strain is highly transmissible you
might want to sequence the s gene and
find out if there are changes
in in the way that the spike protein is
binding to
the receptor it could also be used to
see whether or not in a person has been
vaccinated but it's coming down with
codeword you might want to sequence the
ss gene there to see
if there are changes in the s gene that
might affect the way that
the vaccine uh has been uh um
succeeded or whether the vaccine
successful in that individual in other
words
you could tell whether or not that their
changes in the s gene which are
are um are allowing the vaccine to not
work anymore
so again these three different protocols
have very different purposes
um they're for for reflex testing attack
path for confirming whether or not one
of the highly transmissible strains are
present
or for for examining in detail the s
protein itself
i'll also point out that the fourth
protocol that will be coming out in a
couple weeks by the end of this month we
hope
um is is more open-ended it allows you
to query any region of the genome and
therefore it can answer many more
questions depending on again
if you want to see how the end protein
for example the nuclear capsule protein
might be changing you know we'll have
tools available
for doing that so um
the choice of the protocol really
depends on the questions you want to
want to ask
thank you um we have some great
questions coming in thank you for
submitting these
one of these also says which samples do
you use in that study
so i think that was referring to the uh
the one where i was characterizing the
6970 deletion
uh we had a couple of them one was was
was some strains that we were reflex
testing for a laboratory and the other
one was twist biosciences
cells some reference rnas now that are
derived from the b117 string
and we have used that one as well to
confirm that the that protocol
detects the the uh the dropout
got you okay um the next one do you have
protocol for california variants defined
by cdc as variants of concern
so yes the the fourth protocol that
we're working on will highlight all
variants of concern as they arise and we
plan to
update that every couple of weeks to see
if there are new strains arising that
are that are of concern or
are variants of consequence which is the
higher the highest level that there are
right now
um the the um for right now the protocol
that we've written for the 117 and
the 1 351 strains will work for the
california
variants but if you need to have the uh
the primers chosen for those there are
different mutations
um and and you you use the the wet lab
protocol itself but with different
different sanger sequence primers for
that
if you need to get a hold of those of
those primer sequences uh contact us
we can look up and send you the
sequences uh um that you would use for
for sequencing the california variants
so the short answer is yes the protocols
work for the california variants
you need to contact us before we get the
the final protocol written for the
anywhere contact us to be able to get
the primers
needed to sequence the california
variants
our next one ce data analysis um
see i think they mean does ce data
analysis use
regular gene mapper um
so gene mapper is mostly used for
fragment analysis
and so you you wouldn't use gene mapper
for analyzing sequencing traces
but this these protocols are all all
written to to make use of
any of the of the sanger sequencing
analysis programs that are out there
for example um seekscape seek scanner
um seek a
um all work very well we use some
third-party uh
platforms as well like genius for
example anything that can they can make
use of the a of analyzing ab1 traces can
be used for these protocols itself
these will allow you to to get some very
uh um
general uh sequence reads and you'll get
you can then use that the
the resulting sequence reads to blast
databases to find out their mutations
present
but uh as as uh the the the final
protocol that we're coming out with
we'll have some guidelines for doing
variant analysis
uh using seekscape um and
um and variant reporter these are two uh
pieces of software available from thermo
fisher scientific
um and we will have uh the the the known
variants preloaded into there so that
you can uh quickly identify variants
um that that might be of interest in
your strains
thank you and the next one says
and the results of the mgs they are
identified by
ce results of ngs identified by ce
so you you would use you you could use
ce you know sanger
uh sanger sequencing to confirm any any
results that you get with next-gen
sequencing
um but but the data output of those two
platforms if i'm understanding
this this question correctly the data
output of the two platforms are
different so you can't
you can't take a next-gen um
data and analyze it using the the sanger
sequencing software
um but but what you would do is that if
you get uh you know a novel
mutation identified by by next-gen
sequencing you could take that same
sample
sang or sequence it and confirm that
that variant is present
great and what are the best strategies
for monitoring sars kovi ii
in the environment um so that's a really
good question um
we are um are working with some some of
our customers that
that are uh that have been uh able to
trace uh stars kobe 2
in wastewater for example
um and and what we're learning is that
it it doesn't make a lot of sense
right now when the epidemic or the
pandemic is in a very um
uh wild stage you know we'll say that a
lot of a lot of different different uh
um
people infected with it they're you're
gonna score positive uh results in the
wastewater treatment
um and so practically speaking you will
detect
you'll probably at this stage of the
pandemic you will detect uh
sars kobe 2 in wastewater we haven't
gone so far as to look for strain
identifications in wastewater yet to
just
simply presence or absence of of of
styroscopy and wastewater
now where it might be really effective
there are in places where the um
the pandemic has gotten under control
like for example new zealand
in new zealand they might want to for
example monitor the wastewater to see if
there are
uh new outbreaks that are there um are
present uh in
in a vast in you know in a vast sample
there
by analyzing the wastewater there so in
some cases it might be more practical to
to
monitor uh uh sars kobe 2 in wastewater
rather than actually screen
using using wastewater another really
exciting thing that just really came out
recently was one of the thermometer
divisions um that made a device called
aerosol
sense um this is a device which
uh takes samples from the air and we
have shown in a proof of concept that
you can detect sars kobe 2 virus
in um in settings where it's where it's
concentrated
you can detect stars kobe 2 circulating
in the air using this aerosol sense
device
um so i would watch thermal fissure for
for more results from that
these are very preliminary but we're
very excited about the opportunity to
screen
and to monitor in the environment using
uh this aerosol sense device
thank you i want to thank our audience
for these wonderful questions we have
time for a few more
um what are the viral load requirements
for the ce protocols
so uh the the times that i have tested
it directly is with the uh
the the 6970 deletion and again that has
a pre-amplification step
so that we can make sure that that that
protocol is as sensitive as the attack
path we wanted to make sure that we were
able to get the the viral
detection uh limits of that protocol
that were equivalent attack path and
that turns out to be about 50 gces per
mill uh with that protocol
now we haven't done any limited
detection tests using the other
protocols
we imagine it's not going to be quite as
sensitive as
as the the 6970 because it lacks the
pre-amplification steps there
but we think that that maybe around
around you know 100 to 500 gces per mill
is doable
with those with those protocols um so we
we think um that that that it will be
comparable uh not as
sensitive but as a pcr test or the or
the pre-amplification test but
comparable
the other thing i want to mention is is
that you know one complicating fact with
the uh with the
lods um with
with all these different things or
sequencing primers required for these
other protocols is that we would have to
test the lod for each different amplicon
um and and that would probably vary
quite a bit based on on
on the pcr efficiency of our particular
uh um
primers and the sequence dependency on
the on the efficiencies of that so it
might vary
but we think that that that you know
about 100 to say 500 gces per mil is
doable with these protocols
and what percentage of samples should
you confirm by sequencing for
surveillance so we we have been talking
with a lot of the of the local
and and the national um
public health groups that that are that
are essentially some guidelines for that
and the consensus
is is usually for enough for monitoring
and for and for
surveilling you know the new mutations
as they come up um they're suggesting
five to ten percent
of of um positive samples be screened by
sequencing for
changes um and and for monitoring
but a lot of that's going to depend on
on the local environments and what the
local
uh not only what the what the local
government dictates but also what the
resources available in those regions are
some places are going to are not going
to be able to to sequence that many just
because of of cost constraints
sanger sequencing you know is uh is
of course going to be less expensive
than next gen sequencing um
for uh focused regions there and it
might be necessary
to to just sequence certain regions of
of the genome
that are hypermutable like for example
the s protein in in cases where you know
researchers might be more limiting
will there be updates to the q the
current
qpcr test made to detect the variant
such as
b117 um and b501yv3 or p1 lineage
um i i don't have a firm answer to that
i do know that the
the we are developing uh assays that
will
uh detect mutations arising in those
strains and we have
a uh some panels available um i believe
they're research use only panels but but
they are available for for confirming by
pcr you know whether or not some of
those mutations found in those strains
are present
we also know that the tacpath kit
the techpath assay as designed
it queries three different regions of
the sars genome
and so even though the uh the b117 for
example has the
s gene dropout um that the other two
probes and showed very robust results
and therefore
that the the test was not significantly
affected by the s gene dropout
um because the the the other regions are
not as mutable in the attack path assay
we don't expect there to be a great
change
um in the efficacy of those tests um
when new mutations arise but so but
that's always possible
um i i would check with the uh the uh um
the
uh local representative uh for the uh
the tacpac essay and find out what the
latest is
uh for uh for detecting the new strains
with that assay thank you and we have
time for one more question
how can we confirm new mutations that
appear in a strain
well again so sanger sequencing is
really the best way
to detect new mutations so we'd
recommend confirming new mutations using
sanger sequencing
um as i mentioned we will have the a
protocol available in a couple of weeks
that will give you the flexibility to
choose any region of the
of the genome and find primers that are
specific for that region allowing you to
sang or sequence
anywhere in the sars kobe 2 genome um in
the meantime and before that
that uh um that that protocol and the
browsers that allow you to select the
primaries
available you can get a hold of us here
at thermo fisher scientific and we can
manually search for the primers
necessary that will allow you to confirm
new mutations
that you might have encountered in your
work so just please let us know
we're here to be your partners and we're
here to help you so please just contact
us and we'll help as much as we can
wonderful thank you again steven for
your time today and your important
research
before we go i would like to thank the
audience for joining us today and their
interesting questions
i'd also like to thank our sponsors
thermo fisher scientific for sponsoring
today's webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time
of registration the webcast can be
viewed on demand for two years
until april of 2023 and lab roots will
alert you via email when it is available
for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's
live event thank you again steven until
next time goodbye
bye